[Music]
hi everyone welcome and thank you for
coming to our talk today we are members
of the Android UX team and we're excited
today to talk to you about the new
notifications features in Oh from a UX
perspective so I'm Julie I'm a
researcher on the Android team and today
I'll first tell you about the research
that inspired the new notifications
features in o so in November of 2015 our
team went on what we call au expedition
to learn more about how people
experience notifications so our team of
researchers designers engineers p.m. we
all spent a week in New York and New
Jersey speaking to and observing users
we approached the topic as attention
management to include interruptions from
devices other people around us ourselves
and everything in your environment we
didn't want to limit our scope to just
on-stream smart phone notifications we
use multiple methods in the research we
started by interviewing people but then
we also observed people because
notifications are so contextual and in
the moment we wanted to observe people
receive notifications to see what they
would do and how they would react to
them we also had group discussions
amongst friends who did design exercises
together and lastly we synthesize the
data together as a team and we held a
workshop later women came up with ideas
that turned into the features in ohm so
what did we learn the most striking
observation we made is that there was
this addiction to foam people were bound
to their phones all day because they
were afraid they might miss something
important phone notifications were a
major source of stress people were very
hyper vigilant to any kind of signal
they could be getting from their phones
afraid to miss something important and
most notifications were actually not
important to them only a few were
necessary we heard lots of things like
this from our participants Denise said
if I don't have my phone for two seconds
I freak out what if I miss something and
she was a busy lawyer and I observed her
in her house the whole day constantly
going like this where's my phone where's
my phone and she'd leave the room and
come back looking for her phone just
really anxious all day just in case her
phone wasn't with her
and then there's Alice who's a professor
she said I wish I could have something
like an Amber Alert for my parents
ex-husband and sons school so that those
would override everything else she gets
lots of notifications from different
sources but the only ones she cares
about are these and she wishes these
would always override the others we
observe different coping strategies from
users to block out all of this noise the
first one is to physically put the phone
away so people would force themselves to
put their phone in a purse put in
another room someone even put it in a
box in another room just anything to
prevent yourself from checking it the
other strategy was to not let the device
make noise so let it just vibrate or
don't even let it vibrate at all another
strategy was to not let sources contact
you that means to block all
notifications from an app and the last
one is to do nothing but be constantly
annoyed every day and all day Stephen he
mentioned this particular social
networking app sent me way too many
notifications so I deleted the app so he
got fed up and deleted the app and
actually every day he uses the service
in a mobile browser multiple times a day
purely just so we wouldn't receive
notifications in fact the pattern that
we're hearing now is when people get so
annoyed with notifications whenever they
download a new app by default
they'll just block it all blocked all
notifications without even giving it a
try this is obviously something we don't
we all don't want so we need to really
be careful about this cumulative effect
of all of our apps notifications people
often want only some notifications from
an app but not all of them
so even if they want just one type of
notification they still receive a bunch
of unwanted one and many people don't
adjust their settings even if they know
they can so even if they know there's a
way to do it they might not know how to
do it
or it might feel like a hassle so they
just live with the problem Angie said
notifications are like junk mail you can
take the time to set up filters or just
hit delete I just deal with them just
deals with it every day
Stella said if you allow push
notifications I know there's a way to go
into settings and adjust it but I don't
know how to do that so what else did we
learn there were only two types of
notifications that people needed to know
the first one above all notifications
from other people are most important so
these include SMS messaging apps emails
from people phone calls etc anything
that came from a person on the other end
these were most valued flora said
notifications from other people are most
important I always respond those are the
only ones that she pays attention to and
then there are more important people so
notifications from the inner circle
matter even more so these are people
like your spouse significant other
parents kids closest friends they can
reach us at any time and we keep
channels open and reserved for them
andrew said work emails and text for my
wife are the only things that matter
basically things I need to attend to so
I don't get in trouble so those are the
two types that he cares about above
everything else the other kind of
notification that's important to people
are reminders for things that they need
to do so we observed people having
things they needed to remember
throughout their day like picking up
your dry cleaning calling a credit card
company to follow up with an issue
cleaning a chinchilla cage if that
applies to you setting up a kid's
playdate making new keys with a car
things like that right we all have
things like this in our lives and people
need to remember these
things David took sometimes I get a
notification for something that I
actually want to do but just not at that
moment and then I forget about it later
because I don't see it again and Shelley
says I know I have to pick up my
dry-cleaning but telling me right now is
not going to help me
it's like nagging tell me what I'm near
the dry cleaner so when a notification
isn't address right away it's very easy
to forget it out of sight out of mind we
realize that we need to make it easier
for people to remember these tasks so
while this research as I mentioned was
conducted only in New York in New Jersey
we've observed similar patterns in many
other studies across many locations
since then whatever topic we're studying
from productivity to wearables to
driving we keep hearing over and over
again from people about the stress and
the burden of all the notifications are
being bombarded with so here are some
other locations that we've done where
we've heard similar patterns across the
US and many cities and internationally
so based on this research our team felt
is important for us to respect our users
attention and to allow them to have more
control so this inspired some major
changes in oh this year now here's
Rachel to give you more details about
the features
[Applause]
hi I'm Rachel garb and I'm an
interaction designer and manager for the
Android UX team the first new feature I
want to talk about is channels show of
hands from smartphone users in the room
who here has ever wished that they could
get some of the notifications from an
app but not all of them that's that's
almost all of you yep so knowing that we
definitely wanted to add support in the
Android system so that users could have
more granular control over an apps
notifications in oh we're introducing
channels and here's how it works
you define a channel for each
notification type that you want to send
and then your users are able to make
decisions about notifications at the
channel level let's look at an example
suppose that we are all the designers of
an app for crane air a fuss free
corporate airline that caters to the
frequent flyer and here's all our
existing notifications we've got a
pretty sweet program for our frequent
fliers or as we like to call them
executives we have a set of
notifications for our customers about
the points they've earn and their status
in the program now all of these
notifications you see here have to do
with the executive program so let's make
a channel and call it executive program
now we occasionally also offer discounts
and deals to incentivize our customers
to book more flights so let's group
these notifications together in a
channel and call it discounts and deals
now when we categorize notifications
into channels we want to look for
similar subject matter and similar
importance to users here we have a
number of notifications that could be
sent in the hours and minutes leading up
to the flight so they're pretty
important let's create a channel for
them called flight updates and now with
this example in mind let's shift over to
how users experience channels
the UI design for channels is optimized
for the number one most important use
case which is I don't want this type of
notification from this app now without
channel any support for this use case
has to come from within the app with
settings to block notifications by type
now how did the user find out if an app
provides this they have to open the app
and look at the settings and it's not
like all apps are going to do it the
same way but a lot of the time there
won't be any way to block notifications
by type and at that point the user has
to decide what they're going to do they
can ban the app from sending any
notifications at all they could
uninstall the app or just live with it
and none of these are ideal but with
channels it's a different story one
that's straightforward and consistent
let's check out the UI now we at Crane
Air know that a segment of our users
love to celebrate when they earn points
or reach a new status so whenever they
land we notify them about how many
points they earned on the flight and how
they close how close they are to the
next status level but maybe not all
users want to be notified like this some
might not want any notifications except
the ones that are essential to
functioning in their daily lives and
they know that they can get this
information in their monthly statement
they're fine waiting for it so to stop
this type of notification all a user has
to do is touch and hold it which lets
them see the channel and then they turn
off this switch and tap Done
no more executive program notifications
from Crane Air but they'll still keep
getting the others like those Handy
flights updates now our aim with
channels is to make it possible for
users to get most if not all of their
notify their notification control needs
met inline or one step away in settings
now in settings users can decide
to block all notifications from an app
and new for Oh an app can show a dot on
its icon when it has notifications
waiting for a user but if the user
doesn't ever want to see a dot for that
app they can prevent the app from
showing it users can see all of the
channels at a glance and decide which
ones they want they can view and edit
settings for a given channel more on
that to come and if the app wants to
provide other settings beyond what's
here the app can have a link for the
users back to a screen in the app this
approach bringing more notification
controls into the system makes the user
experience more convenient and
consistent so that is an overview of
channels and next I'd like to talk about
the new behavior model for notifications
in oh and I'll start with the research
that informed it some people are putting
up with unwanted notification behavior
because they're reluctant to use
settings you heard about this from Julie
so the opportunity here was to make it
easier for users to understand and
control notification behavior now let's
compare the current behavior model with
the new one for o in the current model
the app developer uses a field called
priority and set the priority level for
each notification that level maps to a
set of behaviors and some of them are
customizable by the app for example if
you choose hive if you choose priority
level high as the app developer you can
have your notification make sound or not
you can have it vibrate or not you can
have it peak or not a lot for a user to
follow in the new model priority is
deprecated and instead the app developer
sets an importance level for each of
their channels rather than for
individual notifications and there's
fewer customizations that the app can
make on that behavior here you see the
inner workings of priority levels I
won't read this out to you but let's
compare it with importance levels
as you can see we've gone down from five
to four levels and reduced what can be
customized we are intentionally trading
flexibility for simplicity so that users
have a better shot at understanding what
the heck is going on we're letting go of
allowing each notification to behave
differently so that we can guarantee
users that all notifications from the
same channel behave the same way in the
current model a user can control an
app's behavior but has no insight
whatsoever into the apps intentions as
they're making decisions but in the new
model the user gets a clear picture of
app behavior as they make decisions so
it's the difference between I can make
sure that this app won't be able to do X
versus I can see this channel does X but
I'm going to have it do Y instead I will
show you what I mean by comparing the UI
in the current UI if show silently here
is turned on then it's predictable but
otherwise the user has no clue how
notifications from the app will behave
in the new UI the user just needs to
look at the important settings to see
how the channel will behave and if they
don't like it they can choose a
different setting in this new model
Android creates a setting screen for
every channel from every app this is the
place where users go to see and control
its behavior the main settings are to
block the channel and change importance
if the importance level is high enough
the user has sound and vibration options
too and there's more Advanced Options
now you can also optionally provide a
brief description of what the channel
does if it's not obvious so that users
can make more informed decisions if your
app already offers channel like behavior
please
leverage Android solutions so that users
don't run into the situation where
there's discrepancy between an app and
system settings you can link to the
system settings screen either as a
channel or
the apt level and if you want to offer
channel controls beyond what the system
offers for example letting user specify
notification and email preferences in
the same place in your app you can have
a link back to your app settings and
that's an overview of the new importance
model next I'll turn it over to Justin
to talk about other new things for oh
[Applause]
thanks Rachel I'm Justin barber and I'm
a visual designer on Android and I have
to start with an apology because many of
you probably showed up for this session
hoping for a Justin Bieber concert and
it's not happening but I saw some pretty
interesting stuff to talk about so
visual hierarchy is the focus of oh and
if you remember last year an N we
completely redesigned notification
templates to become more flexible modern
much cleaner and the new features and oh
that I'll be covering we're really built
on the foundation that we set in n and
also on Julie's amazing research so
that's where I'll start with the insight
research aside with the research
insights that really led to what our
approach in O so the first insight was
that people are overloaded with
notifications and it's hard to find the
important ones I'm pretty sure we've all
been here before and in Julia's research
were uncovered that users were building
associations seeing to determine what
was important for them so if the phone
made a certain vibration tone or they
saw a certain color of light blinking or
they'd see a color in their notification
they were making associations to
determine whether or not this was
important enough for them to spend time
on but that can be frustrating
misleading and above all time consuming
for go for oh it's resent notifications
in a way that helps users sift through
the noise not just to build more
associations but to build a consistency
and a trust you should know where the
important stuff is going to be before
you have to go looking for it the second
most important insight that led to our
approach was that people are the VIP
notifications and absolutely all
scenarios who is more important than
what or
and so the opportunity here is pretty
simple make people notifications VIPs of
the drawer people matter the most and
notifications is really communications
hubs so we really want to emphasize that
in this space so as I mentioned before n
focused on individual notification
templates and then oh we've zoomed out
to kind of see the bigger picture and
how they all fit together in one
experience specifically by improving the
hierarchy of notifications that appear
in the drawer we did this by designated
for different types of notifications and
four different buckets for them
represented by these yellow blocks
before I get into the details each
different bucket I'll give you the
high-level overview so the first bucket
is for major ongoing this is things like
a phone call the next is
people-to-people like a message from a
friend the third is a general
notifications the best of which are
timely reminders and the fourth or by
the way or bTW these are the four
buckets of notification types and how
they're organized within the drawer
and the purpose of this is to ensure
that notifications most critical to read
first are shown first it also creates
consistency when you pull down the
drawer to find that specific
notification what you're looking for
you'll already know which area to be
looking at because you'll become
familiar with these sections so we're
enabling users to build associations
through these through this ordering and
lastly we're going to be ranking
notifications within each section this
means if you have two message
notifications they're not going to be
separated by something else in the
middle they'll always appear together so
it'll be a lot easier to scan the
notification drawer so now you have a
big picture let's drill down into the
details of each bucket starting with the
first one major ongoing notifications
are really for time-sensitive content
users should actively be aware of this
is like phone call driving directions
timer music and as a developer extended
type of notification to be running a
foreground service or the importance
higher than men or using a media style
of media session for music notifications
and this type of content is for content
that's using device resources that
directly impacts real
life context and the things that match
that is a really really short list the
type of notification will rarely be
appearing in the users drawer because
the context that requires it is a very
rare situation so an N this is kind of
what these types of notifications looks
like right they're not very visually
distinguished they don't necessarily
always appear at the top of the drawer
they can be lost omits to other
notifications and if you wanted the
proper prominence to really gain that
association for the user you had to go
with customization which led to
inconsistency with the rest of
notifications so an O what we're doing
is we're pulling that color from the app
and filling the background with it and
guaranteeing a top spot in a
notification drawer
so these will always appear at the very
top but again because they're so
prominent miss using this type of
notification for something it's not
meant for will be very obvious to users
and with the channels that Rachel just
described it'll be really easy for them
to block this type of notification if it
doesn't align with what it's really
meant to be following into this category
is also music so an N you can see that
the templates are that music samplers
the media templates the most different
template that we have compared to all
the others but it still feels really
generic and it doesn't really look
different from other notifications so an
o we've integrated the album artwork
into the notification and drawn out the
most prominent colors for the background
and as an accent the result is a
beautiful lively notification that
really celebrates the artwork and the
artists behind the music that we really
love and I found myself pulling down the
notification drawers I listen to music
just to see what kind of colors that
song generates now for the next section
people-to-people this is really for
content from a person like a message or
a missed call and as Julie mentioned
people are the VIP notifications so
we're going to put them right at the top
of the drawer in the number one position
since major ongoing is going to be
pretty rare to get this type of
notification you should be set you
should be using messaging style with
direct reply or attaching a contact
to it so as it stands today a message
notification is really not that valuable
and until you interact with it there's
like one line of the message so you
don't know if it's worth actually
expanding and reading and then you
thought to make the decision if you
should reply to it and you may not be
able to reply to it directly within the
drawer you have to jump out of the
drawer
so it's it's really just not that
valuable so in oh we've made one really
subtle change that has actually made a
really big impact on the messaging
experience and that is that we're
exposing more lines of content in the
collapsed state of the notification so
now you can read up to three lines of
the message without having to spend the
time expanding the notification and
deciding what you want to do with it and
we're in continuing to invest heavily in
this area of focus and we're looking
forward to making even more improvements
especially around direct reply coming
soon this next bucket is for general
notifications and the best of which as
we documented in material guidelines and
Julia's research backs up is really
meant for well times and informative
tasks reminders and an oh there's no
behavior or visual change in the
representation of these notifications
but it does play into the next bucket of
bTW and today there are a lot of
notifications being sent in this general
bucket that really should be sent in oh
as a bTW bTW by the way notifications
are meant for contextual or informative
but non urgent content we heard a lot of
stories from Julie's research about how
people felt so overwhelmed if content in
the drawer isn't urgent it should be
sent as a bTW things like weather
updates or traffic or suggestions and
promotions so early in this presentation
Rachel used crane air as an example of
how to organize your apps notifications
into channels if you remember there are
three different channels executive
program flight updates and discounts and
deals and that last category of
discounts and deals is an excellent
example of what should be sent as a bTW
notifications and it's pretty simple to
send one you just need to set the
importance of the notification to min
so an N the visual representation of
these notifications is pretty equal with
all the other notifications the only
difference was a slightly different
colored background it's a pretty
heavyweight presentation for content
that's actually very lightweight it's
bothersome of the users it takes up a
lot of space so what we've done in o is
we've taken the app name and the first
line of the notification and simplified
that down into a single line so the new
presentation is really meant to feel
lightweight so that users don't feel
bothered by them they don't need to
manage them because they're out of the
way and it's okay if they can glance
that and don't want to take action on it
right now you can also set your
notification to automatically expire so
that users also don't have that burden
of having to manage them as well the
advantage of this is that instead of
risking annoying your users by sending a
notification in that general bucket you
can send it as a bTW instead this way
you don't have to hurt users trust by
risking something you can just put it in
the bTW section also the full
functionality still remain so if the
user taps on this bTW it expands the
full notification you get all the color
and if the notification has actions with
it those will appear as well so when you
put it all together that comes it comes
together really nicely you can actually
tell a very intentional order within the
drawer and when we compare that with n
that's when you can really start the
difference you can really see the
differences come out if you squint your
eyes and look at n which is on the left
and the black phone frame you can't
really tell which notification is which
at a glance we've look at oh it's really
clear you can see the major ongoing at
the top you can see the bTW at the
bottom you can even kind of tell it it's
a people-to-people a message
notification because it's taller than
the rest now you can also see an n how
when there's an overflow of
notifications those notifications got
stacked behind the ones that were
visible this doesn't match up super well
with the spatial model of the full width
notifications so on o we've improved
that spatial model and made it feel much
more unified have a really beautiful
animation and the point of this is to
correlate the notifications of icons of
how they appear in the set
spar with the notifications that they
are in the drawer and again yeah pretty
cool right this is something we're
really really proud of and again it
wouldn't have been possible without
those template changes that we made in n
right so we're taking steps to unify the
whole experience you can also see on
stead of stacking at the bottom overflow
notifications fit into a shelf and we
have a really beautiful experience going
on I'll just let it play one more time
all right so this is the last feature
I'll be covering pretty briefly and
that's snoozing and this feature came
directly out of user research the
insight was that people need to remember
the things they need to do and today you
only have two options if you can't deal
with a notification right now you can
either just miss the notification and
count on your memory which if you're me
never works ask my wife or you can leave
the notification in the shade but it can
get lost amidst a ton of other
notifications right it's either/or so
our opportunity was to give users more
ways to do this in the drawer so let's
say you're in a meeting and you get a
text from a friend asking about dinner
now you're in the meeting so you can't
reply right away but you know as soon as
you we as a meeting your minds already
going to be on to the next task and
you're not going to remember to reply so
instead of letting the notification
linger in the shade linger in the drawer
or dismissing it altogether you can
snooze it and this is how you can do a
partial swipe which reveals two
different icons you'll notice additional
icon to the gear that we introduced in
10 and this is the button for snooze so
if you tap this icon the notification
will automatically be snooze and you'll
get a confirmation of this snooze with
an option to undo it if you need to so
snoozing the notification will set it to
come back in that set duration with the
exact same interrupted qualities that
are sent with as before so if it made a
vibration zone when it came in the first
time and you can use it it'll by
again the second time when it comes back
so if you want a different time than one
hour you can just tap that arrow and
you'll get a few different options to
change that duration and the option that
you select then will then be set as the
default duration the next time you
snooze and notifications pretty simple
that's what we have to show you for the
new notifications in oh and if you're
interested in finding out even more
especially from more detailed
engineering perspective there's an
earlier talk what's new and
notifications launch icons and shortcuts
that we encourage you to check out we're
really excited about these improvements
and believe that these features are not
only beneficial to users but will also
increase the quality of engagement their
apps thanks so much
[Applause]
[Music]